yeah such a huge headache well the
Christmas spirit is turning into a
travel nightmare for many today would
have been one of the last safe Windows
to travel out before the Midwest gets
slammed with winter weather causing
whiteout conditions and now many are
finding themselves stranded right here
in Las Vegas
I'll Be Home for Christmas A Promise
many of you probably gave to your love
once maybe we won't be home for
Christmas that would be sad but now
Travelers like the tissuers are racing
against the clock their flight to Idaho
got canceled Wednesday and they are set
to get on a flight the next day we might
be canceled tomorrow who knows Thursday
major winter storms are supposed to slam
most of the Midwest the National Weather
Service is calling it a once in a
generation storm if we book it tomorrow
tomorrow's actually the storm so it
doesn't make sense so I might not even
leave until Friday and according to
FlightAware more than 700 flights flying
in or out of the country have already
been canceled for Thursday Spirit
canceled the flight while we were
waiting in line father of two AJ Stone
thought he was safe to fly out of Las
Vegas a day before the storms but he was
proved wrong try to find another flight
on another airline today to get out but
they're about a thousand bucks for us to
go one way so we're just going to
hopefully go tomorrow or maybe drive up
frustrated Travelers may find themselves
on the phone with Airlines this morning
what I called Allegiant and Southwest
both had busy signals in the afternoon a
busy signal again for Allegiant but
Southwest was a wait time as well as
Delta current whole time is 52 minutes I
don't want to spend Christmas here I
really don't
now some others that I spoke with say
they had to go through security and get
to the gate to find out if their flight
was even canceled and while I was on the
phone with Delta they were saying that
if you do not have a flight out within
the next 72 hours to just go to their
website to make any changes Victoria
Saha eight news now Victoria thank you
if you are planning to travel this
weekend make sure you're checking for
all the updates on your flight status on
a regular basis at last check there were
nine departures canceled and seven
arrivals also have been canceled